the simplest way to find out is the
future of me test so if you are
wondering the same just take a look at
the leadership in your same company do
you want to be like that leader do you
admire or enjoy the lifestyle that he or
she currently have as for me yes the
Consulting lifestyle was glamorous to a
certain point however whenever I look at
the partners at McKinsey their lifestyle
I knew deeply that that was not the life
that I had in mind I think that's very
valid right thinking about the next best
people in the hierarchy or your leads
your team leads what does their life
look like and yeah I think it's
understandable if you look at the
partners how late they work how busy
they are how stressed they often are and
then think for yourself and decide for
yourself this is not a career for you